so we got the best safety in the NFL
Jamal Adams and we got a little bit
upset that you guys can't hit people
this year you cannot well they're okay
okay so do you feel that you want to hit
people more most definitely man it's
getting so it is a wussy quarterback and
I think it's getting we're tired of it
so we brought him to the wrecking club
in New York and we're gonna smash some
crap you down let's do it my haters
that's incredible the ceiling game we're
tired of your constant winning and your
sustained excellence and you get all the
calls and we're just done with it high
hate you so much but those who said I
couldn't cover grown
Wow I felt like a lot of he had a lot of
frustration man uh damn it look at that
yeah he's got to go to the blue tent now
I'm sick of being accessible all the
time I'm sick of walking around New York
City with everybody like this and they
don't even look at anybody anymore
new phone who dis this is to every
person in the Instagram comment section
with a big mouth and I was a good one
they're doing an hour-long Phil Simms
special what do you think about it
though we need to fix this TV yeah that
will leave any of the stress oh
definitely man so damn good
see that's why people come on the Sims
and let go with the players show we are
here for you ah damn you tell you what
receivers are in trouble because now
he's loosened up and ready to go
overweight